ce concorde de british airways qui s'est
posée la nuit dernière sur le tarmac de
l'aéroport de heathrow est peut-être le
dernier supersonique a volé à son bord
il n'y avait aucun passager juste
l'équipage chargé de le ramener de new
york les sept concorde de la compagnie
britannique sont maintenant cloués au
sol jusqu'à nouvel ordre
comme les cinq appareils d'air france on
en garde depuis la catastrophe
la compagnie britannique a anticipé la
recommandation des enquêteurs français
et anglais en france le bea le bureau
enquête accident a préconisé
officiellement aujourd'hui la suspension
du certificat de navigabilité du
concorde
en clair le retrait de son permis de
voler à partir du moment où nous avons
déterminé que le risque d'éclatement
groupe ne pouvait provoquer des dégâts
aussi est ce ordinaire en aussi claude
ottan successeur important il devenait
nécessaire de recommander que l'on
prenne des mesures permettant de
garantir contre les conséquences d'un
tel événement
l'éclatement d'un pneu est un incident
banal mais sur le concorde il est à
l'origine de la catastrophe
c'est ce qu'elle confirmait ce matin
l'autorité de l'aviation civile
britannique qui vient d'interdire
provisoirement les vols du concorde
les britanniques ont devancé que de
quelques heures leurs homologues
français de la dgs et la direction
générale de l'aviation civile
maintenant que l'interdiction est
effective des deux côtés de la manche
les autorités aéronautiques vont se
tourner vers les constructeurs nous
demanderons aux constructeurs bea
systems airbus dont bretagne et
aérospatiale en france de bâtir un plan
d'action qui garantissent un niveau
satisfaisant de sécurité concernant les
risques liées à l'éclatement des pneus
demain françaises et britanniques
doivent se retrouver à londres objet de
la réunion
les modifications à apporter au concorde
pour qu'il puisse un jour retrouver les
routes du ciel